&gt;&gt; So, the thing about entering these points, is that there are actually a ton
of different ways you can do it. I simply wanted to give you one method that you
can use that's pretty reliable for creating different fraction slots in ordered
pairs. So, for our first point, 3 quarters comma negative 1 half, you could, of
course, use this method that I showed you up here. But you could also just enter
this from left to right and it should turn out just like this. So, for some
ordered pairs involving fractions, things aren't really that complicated.
However, this one right here is a pretty difficult one, I think. If you try, for
example, to enter to everything in here from left to right, here's what you'll
end up with, you open parenthesis and then a 1 comma 2 as a denominator over 7.
That's definitely not what we want. So here, I think it's easiest if you first
enter the fraction 2 over 7 then go backwards and write the 1 and the comma.
Negative 1 over 8 comma 3 is another one that's pretty simple to enter. You can
also do this from left to right, or you can use the method of inserting
fractions that's where you need them first. So, the moral of the story is, when
your typing things using MathQuill, you always need to be super careful to check
what you're typing and make sure that it's actually what you want to be typing.
Also, the more practice the better. So, just keep trying things like this out,
any chance you get.